um rasante é de itaqui ma
gente que vocês pensam sorte que é uma
bênção ou uma obra necessária que vocês
pensam sobre os ricos
eu cresci ouviu os rios eram uma família
que tinha uma mentalidade muito bacana
deixava sobre a riqueza
ele fez também tive dos meus pais
incentivo ao trabalho e aos estudos
tive a oportunidade de também receber
muitos outros ensinamentos para a vida
do meu pai em cinco estados
um dia cheguei onde queria
a academia da força aérea acham que lá
eu iria despontar especialmente para a
riqueza
comecei lá houve ações de instrutores
quase que diariamente que dizia assim se
você quiser enriquecer troca de
profissão que aqui você não vai cair
felizmente eu não acreditei nisso mas
outros que por lá passaram acreditava
nisso mais frágil
padrón lá deparei-me com os colegas
completamente interditados e aquilo me
preocupo e procurando bahls
nessa busca por ajuda o problema e
consultor que não existia na época
e aí ele porque estudar o assunto
enquanto mais estudava mais eu me
colocava mais me apaixonava pelo tema e
aí virou uma profissão para lima costa
tem essa realidade mais tarde ao ser
designado comandante subir entre é
constatei isso mais tarde já tem um
trabalho de consultor onde houve as
famílias brasileiras completamente
indignados como vocês podem observar
desgraça imagem
nós considerarmos lado esquerdo da
figura as três principais colunas as
três maiores como um dos nós queremos
observar que 85% das famílias
brasileiras estão com alguma dificuldade
para chegar ao final do mesmo a sua
renda familiar
isso é um problema global no brasil
interessante que
é interessante que apesar disso tudo
aparece parecer que envolve falta de
conhecimento por falta de noção tipos de
conhecimento matemático financeiro
nós observamos que isso independe de
conhecimento e independe de de
conhecimentos financeiros matemáticos
nós observamos que existe o componente
que a gente não conseguia entender e
conseguia desenvolver para melhorar essa
nossa
ah é
atingir pessoas que tinham dificuldades
em matemática facilidade uma caixa com
facilidade com que nossas essas cidades
não refletiu em que anos financeiros
também em ajuste nos seus pronto lá é
atende também pessoas pouco letrados que
números menores evidentemente que tinham
um grande potencial financeiro como por
exemplo contratos de deus que não tenha
terminado o dia chegou por aqui já
aposentado dizendo que tinha 1 milhão
para investir tão preocupado né pelo
técnico russo conseguiu fugir
eu sou chamado deles sendo feliz e
realizado eu preciso de muito ou pra ver
o que precisamos para viver sempre
guardar um pouquinho quando falta alguma
coisa da terra
eu ia fazer tudo aqui pronto ea mulher
vai escorrer para fora
então essas questões são muito
interessantes porque nós temos o caminho
a descobrir por que determinadas pessoas
quase aí na frente eu conhecer essa
figura linda maravilhosa
lançam-se segundo casamento e no caminho
desse esse trabalho nós nos preparamos e
essa figura
agora a gente precisa entender como as
pessoas lidam com o sus porque esse
lidar com o dinheiro tem a ver com
algumas remoções estão artigos para
estudar e emoções o que isso desenvolve
e que isso tem na próxima a gente gera a
começar por nós mesmos precisamos
desconstruir aquela mentalidade de
dinheiro que nós tínhamos no passado
começamos a desconstruir aquela
mentalidade que nossas famílias que os
nossos é nosso tour
venho colocando na nossa vida então nós
começamos a pesquisar e descobrir que
uma série de coisas
percebendo assim na sociedade brasileira
com outras culturas também
william antes frente a riqueza nós
começamos a observar que quase todo
mundo é nossa cultura
cresci ouvindo coisas negativas o
dinheiro toda riqueza nosso melhor não
precisar ser possível ampliar essa
presença
nós poderíamos começar a transformar
essas crenças diretran em crenças pm
soro e começamos a trabalhar com nossa
ciência e conosco mesmos de que a
riqueza está em toda parte
a gente começou a convidar as pessoas a
refletirem a vem a riqueza na natureza
café rica com gosto de mais abundante
demais porque nós fazemos parte dessa
natureza porque não somos ricos
transformarem interior e material
assim nasceu o projeto cresceu e dizer
que é um projeto pessoal fala que
resolvemos então trabalhar com as
crianças nesse projeto porque com as
crianças eu diria que conseguia
distribuir falar dessa edição dessa
permissão para crescer
essa permissão pra levar riqueza diante
para aceitar requerido de todo o gado
embora essa é uma profissão a pesquisa
ou seja um bom dinheiro se quiser ser um
excelente médico que seja um excelente
médico mas que seja não é esse projeto é
e tinha outro ao nosso nossos ao a nossa
necessidade da sociedade e fácil em em
casa trazendo um ganho há anos a
situação muito grande a gente apresenta
o projeto as pessoas focam a nossa está
precisando é nosso conceito de balada e
na seleção vai ensinar as pessoas a
pensar grande e não sabe o que é a
farinha do circuito da vitimização da
reclamação e começaram a contabilizar
uma freqüência de gratidão e de ação é
possível que a gente pode transformar
que a gente pode aprender que tem um
caminho vasco que pode ser explorado que
isso é possível
é possível também o primeiro dever para
depois vão sair de uma ferramenta
positiva na sociedade trabalhando com as
crianças elas a noção da
responsabilidade das crianças desde cedo
começaram a prestar atenção que elas
pensam em que elas sentem em que elas
falem e no impacto disso no ambiente à
volta dela e começamos a trabalhar
naquela atitude delas assumir
responsabilidade de cuidar do próprio
lixo pelas criam a organizar os próprios
pertences assumir a responsabilidade
pelo que elas consentindo expressar o
outro mostrar o rosto elas estão
sentindo com respeito sem invadir a
outra vez o outro colega então trabalho
tem dado muitos frutos também nesse
sentido de engajamento social nem a
gente construir uma sociedade mais
responsável que é possível gerar riqueza
e trabalho não precisa ser um trabalho
cansativo chá e ea gente fazia o
trabalho da criança na psicologia eu
sempre fui muito inquieta deixem de ser
nova sempre questionei no comportamento
das pessoas e uma coisa que entregava
muito a ver tantas pessoas lidarem de
forma diferente com dinheiro que não
sabiam se organizar e outros não sabia o
que não sabia que não tinha fundos do
banco e continuam gastando convencer
essas pessoas então entregou sempre
estudei muito e comecei a buscar um dos
estudos da minha terapia
algumas respostas que foram depois
fundamentar esse trabalho em muitas
coisas
indo a um dos atendimentos que eu fazia
com meus clientes é que muitas pessoas
escolheram a profissão pelo mercado de
trabalho buscando essa estabilidade
financeira
só que isso depois na frente ficava uma
armadilha porque porque ninguém aguenta
ficar muito tempo trabalhando com uma
coisa que não tem a ver com ela
isso acaba sendo uma violência ea pessoa
vai ser feita impedir a venda
muitas vezes até a multidão e quando a
pessoa tem uma legislação muito grande
que acontece
ela começa a consumir mas já tem um ateu
maior porque com a vida tá ruim
uma tarde infeliz a aborrecida ela tem
cada vez ter mais coisas para poder
aliviar um pouco esse mal está crescendo
ea gente está apostando nessa idéia de
que a gente pode ter sucesso a gente
possa construir uma autonomia financeira
com qualquer profissão onde partida é
que essa posição tem a ver o seu ser
pessoa porque trabalho que a gente
escolhe é a maneira de enfrentar o mundo
gente dizer com quem a gente é que marca
a gente quer deixar que ele é ligado a
gente fechar então isso é uma escolha
muito importante que a gente queria só
ver que estava sendo orientado por
oceanos e os jóis maneira equivocada
então a gente tem trabalhado muito com
os pais e com de educadores
a regra não se acreditarem no
desenvolvimento desse talento especial o
conhecimento que as pessoas
mas é equilibrada consigo mesma
foram mais felizes têm condição de fazer
uma carreira melhor de construir um
melhor também
com isso queremos colocar vocês nós
educadores a repensar o processo de
educação trânsito ao aquele processo de
educação que reforça e vai atrás das
dificuldades da criança
ao invés reforçar as suas sociedades
em matemática a prova professor de
matemática mas ele não tá bem mais
embaixo mas elevou em busca por que não
ao invés de contratar professores marta
rocha chamar um pouco a pessoa que busca
incentivar o garoto assim como será este
moço que a gente gostaria de dizer para
vocês sim a gente faça esse trabalho com
as crianças
esse trabalho serve pra todos os lados
para todo mundo ainda batem porque o que
nós carregamos dentro de nós uma criança
interior
a criança que nós fomos um dia é o modo
de nós está um pouco adormecida mas a
gente pode acordar é aquela nossa parte
acredita que o mundo pode ser melhor
aquela parte que sente jovem pode
colocar esse lado alerta o uso de um
outro jeito pra olhar com esses dons e
colocar em risco a sociedade e eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês que
seu trabalho ao longo dos anos com
dinheiro veio a partir de uma ferida que
eu tive pessoal com dinheiro quando era
criança meus pais tiveram a falência ea
nossa família embora tivesse poucos
recursos eram tudo ficam sem nada
então esteja muito difícil de muitas
privações duas telas mas é uma
experiência que ensinou muitas coisas
porque a partir dessa ferida eu comecei
a buscar depois de adulto é mais velho
começou a buscar saídas
sons a entender esse tipo de problema e
eu pude começar a transformar essa dor
num bom e eu gosto muito da imagem da
pena que da concha negar a reagir ao
altar de um grande aí e esse grão de
areia que de flagra é esse alto algum
defeito da puxa de hoje muito tempo e se
transforma numa tela maior
eu gostaria de sair daqui também
pensando nas 2 vocês meus queridos de
vocês da vida e todo mundo tem faz parte
da história de cada um que essas dores
podem ser transformadas em tons que a
gente possa colocar a decisão depois de
serviços à comunidade
o planeta tem melhor então você chegar
longe em casa nem a notar alguma
experiência difícil vocês tiveram na
vida como vocês podem transformar essa
experiência ea um vaidoso ser colocadas
a serviço da humanidade porque um
talento gente só tem sentido se for
dividir compartilhada com uma lâmpada
que a gente atende a nato não faz
sentido ela ficar embaixo da mesa tem
sido de natureza ambiente ea gente
gostaria de dizer pra vocês que nós
realmente acreditamos que uma corrida
transformado num porque como dizia rui
barbosa que é uma frase que nos toca
muito ele dizia assim onde existe uma
criança
e aqui nós acrescentamos de qualquer
laxe tudo pode começar